that's why meeting here today with our
northern European partners and allies is
so important it was great to hear from
president zielinski about their needs
and the UK has played a leading role in
providing Ukraine with the military
support that they require to repel
Russian aggression and indeed push back
and regain the territory which is
rightfully theirs that was a topic of
our conversations here today I'm pleased
to say that there's widespread support
amongst our northern European allies to
continue supporting Ukraine you know we
stand United in that motivation you know
our resolve is strong and zelenski and
Ukraine will continue to get the support
that they need it's something that the
United Kingdom and everyone in it should
feel enormously proud of the part that
we've played let's talk about domestic
issues strikes first of all it is
entirely possible this week prime
minister that people might needlessly
die because of this strike action many
people saying why will you not sit down
with the unions and talk about pay and
ensure that people get the healthcare
they deserve ahead of Christmas
well it's really important to me that
the government is always acting
reasonably and indeed fairly and making
the right long-term decisions for the
country and that's been our approach
throughout the pay setting and
negotiations with the public sector now
that our door is always open the health
secretary has been very clear with that
of course we're always happy to sit down
and talk to people to try and work
through difficult challenges like this
that's always been the case and when it
comes to pay it's because these things
are difficult that we have an
independent process we have an
independent body that makes
recommendations to the government about
what reasonable and fair pay settlements
are now the government accepted those
recommendations in full across the
public sector even though in many cases
those recommendations were higher than
what the government had originally
suggested and indeed higher than what
many people in the private sector are
achieving but the government increased
its offer so it could accept those
independent recommendations in full I
thought that was the reasonable and the
fair thing to do because it's really
important that we combat inflation and
this inflation which is making everybody
in the UK's life difficult I'm
determined to grip inflation to reduce
it and part of us doing that is having a
responsible and fair approach to pay and
that's what we're doing can you reassure
or guarantee that people will not die
this week because of these strikes I
mean we are talking about paramedics
walking up and nurses have been on
strike yeah well I'm really disappointed
to to see that the unions are calling
these strikes particularly at Christmas
particularly when it has such a an
impact on people's day-to-day lives with
the disruption it causes and the impact
on their health and I'd urge them to
keep considering whether these drugs are
really necessary and do everything they
can to alleviate the impact it's going
to have on people and of course a
government for its part is being
responsible and putting in place
contingency measures to make sure we're
well prepared to handle the disruption
that is coming let's talk about Rwanda
you had the victory in their high court
today many people asking now when are
the flights going to take off I mean
they've been promised for months and
months is it going to happen soon well I
welcome the decision of the court today
we've always maintained that our Rwanda
policy is lawful I'm pleased that was
confirmed today and this is just one
part of our plan to tackle illegal
migration last week I set out a very
comprehensive approach to stopping the
boats from coming to the UK it's not
going to be easy and we're not going to
be able to do it overnight but I'm
confident that with the steps I laid out
last week we really can get to grips
with illegal migration because I think
what we all want to see and what I want
to deliver is a system whereby if you
come to the UK illegally you will not
have the right to stay and we will be
able to return you to your own country
if it's safe or a safe alternative like
Rwanda that's a common sense position I
think of the vast majority of the
British public it's my position and
that's what I want to deliver as prime
minister Jeremy Clarkson's been
criticized
in the last 24 hours or so in fact I
think he's in many ways just apologizing
in the last couple of hours about
comments he wrote in the Sunday Times
yesterday regarding the Duchess of
Sussex do you feel that actually for
lots of commentators that kind of
misogyny and racism to a degree is
acceptable uh in some of our newspapers
or among some of our well-known
commentators I think for everyone in
public life language matters and you
asked about racism now I I absolutely
I've seen some of the things that have
been said I absolutely don't believe
that Britain is a racist country and I'd
hope that as in our nation's first
British Asian prime minister when I say
that it carries some wage you know I'm
really proud of our country it's culture
it's resilience it's Beauty and actually
it's an enormous privilege to Champion
Britain and indeed its institutions like
the monarchy when I'm out and about on
the world stage as I am here today and
just very finely and again someone's
been criticized it is Gary Neville for
comment he made equating equatori
migrant workers with the nurses that
have gone on on strike what do you think
of that comparison many feel that it's
unfair he's not rolling back though he
says it's entirely Justified no I don't
I don't think that's right at all in
fact and if you look at our track record
AI track record as transfer I've always
done everything I can to support our NHS
and indeed the wonderful people who work
in it I grew up in an NHS family I spent
my life working in my mum's Pharmacy
when I was younger and if you look at
what we did during covid we provided
enormous support to the front line at a
time when it comes to pay when everyone
else in the public sector experience
they pay freeze the one group that was
singled out for special treatment were
the NHS workers rightly who received
that support but also beyond that for
nurses in particular we've put in place
nurses bursaries when they're training
to become nurses the unions asked for a
training budget once they qualified and
again as Chancellor we put that in place
they're given us as the support they
need so look I I know things are
difficult at the moment for people up
and down the country with inflation of
course I get that that's why we've put
an enormous amount of support in place
of people's energy bills 900 pounds this
winter for a typical family that gives
you a demonstration that we care about
this and we want to find a sensible way
through on pay but I think it's I think
it's entirely right for me to stand here
and say that we have treated everyone
reasonably and fairly and will continue
to do that and you enjoyed the World Cup
yesterday yes for the bits of it that I
managed to catch in between uh in
between my meetings and work it was a
fantastic World Cup final great football
match shame that we were not there but
in the absence of us being there to see
and vape and the meta and Messi go head
to head was uh fantastic and you know
well deserved for Messi to get his World
Cup